sí muy bien dicho raúl rebrote porque
aquí todavía no se habla de segunda ola
hay que decir que desde hace diez días
son más o menos en francia cada día hay
cerca de diez mil casos como decía
estuvo ayer nueve mil 784 con 46
fallecidos pero además el pasado lunes
hubo una cifra
granados los hospitalizados fueron más
que el 11 de mayo el día en que finalizó
el confinamiento en francia hay 862
clusters o focos de contagio y 84
departamentos de 101 en zona roja esto
es con una amplia circulación del cob y
19 erika y le pregunto ahora entonces
qué dice el gobierno ante esta situación
de rebrotes
hay preocupación en el gobierno de
manuel macro raúl ha trascendido que en
el gobierno se preocupan y dicen que la
estrategia de los tests no ha funcionado
se hacen cerca de 1 millón por semana
pero aparentemente los resultados llegan
muy tarde por lo mismo a partir de ayer
se autorizaron los test antígenos
rápidos que dan los resultados dentro de
media hora y se autorizó también a los
kinesiólogos a aplicar los tests psd re
ya que los laboratorios tienen largas
colas cada día y se va a privilegiar que
sean las personas que tienen síntomas y
aquellos que tuvieron contacto con una
enferma con 19 quienes vayan a los
laboratorios también se ha pedido al
ministro de salud que sea claro con la
estrategia que sea transparente y por lo
mismo hoy él va a dar nuevamente un
informe a los franceses en televisión
sobre el estado de la pandemia y sobre
la estrategia que el gobierno va a
seguir hay que decir que una asociación
de víctimas del país 19 ha puesto una
denuncia en contra del primer ministro
castex por la manera en que el gobierno
está manejando nuevamente la pandemia o
este rebrote dicen que el gobierno da
más prioridad a la economía que a la
salud de los franceses
erika gracias como siempre por toda la
información desde la capital francesa